potager situé près de la vallée du
cousin jean claude leduc le sait il a
interdiction d'arroser ses légumes en
journée entre 8h et 19h le secteur du
cousin était placée en seuil de crise
par la préfecture
ils utilisent donc avant tout loue
depuis stockés dans ces bidons pour
l'arrosage de ses plans on arrose le
matin alors le soir très tard parce que
le militaire est pour la nuit et le
lendemain vous êtes tranquille vous
recommencez le méditer reste dans le sol
messi fait trop de soleil ça arrive
adversaire à cuire les légumes et fans
du sport
pour le moment quatre bassins sur les
onze que compte le département ont été
placés en seuil de crise le sera un bon
l'armançon un nom la cure est le cousin
l'exploitation de francis letellier est
situé sur un bassin placés en alerte
renforcée en pleine moisson du maïs il
lui est interdit d'irriguer ces cultures
entre 12h et 20h
une décision qui selon lui pénaliser
tous les agriculteurs du secteur
c'est injuste comment c'est fait s'est
décidé à dijon par la dréal sans venir
même voir les ressources en eau
disponibles et aujourd'hui on sait par
exemple que moi j'ai la chance d'avoir
une ressource en eau disponibles qui
appartient à l'état un cv n f
mais où il y avait 14 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau disponible à l'entrée de
l'été et aujourd'hui on nous dit mais
non vous pouvez pas la ressource en eau
est difficile
il faut restreindre non c'est faux on a
pas on n'aurait pas dû subir de
restrictions d'eau la cause de cette
situation la sécheresse des sols avec
l'absence marqué de pluies depuis
plusieurs semaines les orages de cet été
n'ont pas vraiment d'effet pour la
recherche des daims phréatique a
toujours une tendance à la baisse au
niveau des nappes avec l'été d'omettre
qui sont suivis par la dréal donc là en
l'absence de pluies significatives à la
fois en durée mais à la fois en termes
de on préfère une des petites pluies
plutôt qu'un gros épisode orageuse qui
va permettre davantage de recharger les
sols selon l'évolution de la situation
hydrologique les mesures de restriction
des usages de l'eau pourrait
s'intensifier